the council initiated this service to
improve the housing stock of self
there's a lot of substandard housing in
shelton as far as their cold and damp
and quite expensive to run so it's a
service to help the the tenants
landlords and homeowners of invercargill
improve their housing and make it more
efficient my role entails going out to
people's homes doing a one hour to our
assessment on the home to go over the
home and find where their home is is not
performing well and areas they can
improve to make it warmer and healthier
and also make their their parallels
lower first of all you check the
insulation and and see if it's a need
some on the ceiling under the floors
then I just generally do a room-to-room
assessment of the house looking at
appliances how they heat the home how to
improve their curtains how to improve
the installation of the home in general
and also see if there's any problems as
far as moisture and mold if you look at
here you can see it gap between your
curtain rail and your wall and your
clothes your cut the gap still there so
all that warm air up here will come and
drop down here and cool down and come
out the bottom is cold air so it's
really important to try and close this
off you can and it may be that you have
a closed rail or these rails can be
turned around and screwed to the wall or
the old pelmets that these two have and
other older houses are really good at
stopping that conviction of ear which
then loses its energy and also look at
the seals on your windows here guess
that the rubber start get very stiff so
there should be due for a change soon
and it's a mirror you just go along buy
some new seals and have them stick them
on there quite an expensive yeah
important to check the seals on your
fridge here it's longer they're nice and
spongy and soft and have no cracks in
them because it stops the cold getting
out and your fridge running too too hard
so it's always a good point to check all
the seals along your fridge and make
sure that they're sealing the fridge
properly and
if you close your fridge and it's hard
to pull again that generally means your
seals are in good condition okay we'll
go over here to check your hot water
it's important that your hot water is
not too hot because you're paying the
electricity to heat this hot water and
if you can't hold your fingers under the
hot water for more than three seconds
and it student ly too hot so get through
the maximum temperature and if still
feels comfortable or starts to get hot
after three seconds as a good indicator
you've got at the right temperature
because we need the temperature come and
get 55 degrees in the tip but it should
be 60 degrees at your cylinder to kill
off an allegiant ears that may be in the
system with your heat pump that's really
important to make sure that you have it
set correctly so you're not wasting
energy it's important to have your
control set up on heat mode a lot of
people have it on auto which means that
the system fights with itself to get the
correct temperature but heat will just
turn itself off when it reaches that
temperature and then also have your fan
on auto so then it will make the heat
even in that in the room so rather than
having it fighting itself ever set up
correctly it's also very important to
make sure that your filters are cleaned
so you can actually just pop it up here
these are your filters here and you can
slide them out run your vet can clean up
over those to take all the way that dust
and he does sitting up here and then you
can slide them back in if we come
outside I can say some of the things
that you need to be weary of outside the
vents along here are really important
for the house to breathe and the floor
to get rid of moisture so if you can
keep things away from in front of events
especially plants that things that might
block it up also if you look at your
guttering maintain your guttering so you
don't get things growing in it so water
won't spill over and then run onto the
house and then slowly get into the house
that way the numbers found on the web or
they can directly ring the council and
ask for the service just ask for the
echo design advisor and put through the
mean or only girls at the front and they
can book the inspection for me it's all
about the people living in the house
much as the house